und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka guten abend um
kurz nach 18 uhr dürften ziemlich viele
politisch interessierte menschen
hierzulande eine art braig cit moment
gehabt haben verblüffung darüber dass
das etwas unwahrscheinlichere von zwei
szenarien eingetreten ist die spd
mitglieder haben die bis vor kurzem
unbekannte abgeordnete saskia esken und
den mäßig bekannten ex landespolitiker
norbert walter borjans zu ihrer neuen
partei chefs geführt und dabei nebenbei
ihren wichtigsten bundesminister und
vizekanzler quasi rasiert formal gewählt
wird das neue duo auf dem parteitag ende
nächster woche
es freuen sich die jusos oder es
gratuliert die linkspartei der rest der
republik ist erstmal perplex und fragt
sich und was wird jetzt aus der großen
koalition dazu gleich ein interview mit
norbert walter borjans doch zuvor
berichten andreas huppert und lars
bohnsack vom abend in berlin
so sehen sie also aus die sieger im
duell um den spd vorsitz saskia esken
und norbert walter borjans sollen der
alten dame spd neues leben einhauchen
ihr wieder selbstvertrauen geben und vor
allem mehr linkes profil
ja wir müssen ein stück nach links ich
glaube das ist auch im sinne eines
funktionierens der beiden volksparteien
dass die nicht als jemand ein
siamesischer zwillinge aneinander
schrumpfen sondern die beide deutlich
machen es gibt links von der mitte und
es gibt und rechts von der mitte und da
stehen wir ganz sicher dafür dass für
eine politik links der mitte brauchen
diese politik links der mitte haben die
genossen ihm nicht zugetraut
olaf scholz der vizekanzler und
finanzminister ist der große verlierer
unklar die zukunft des groko befürworter
in partei und regierung die entscheidung
bedeutet eine neue parteiführung und
hinter der müssen sich jetzt alle
versammeln
das ist das was für die spd in der
zukunft wichtig ist damit wir eine
starke partei werden so wie wir uns im
vorfeld ja auch in die hände hinein
versprochen hatten gegenseitig dass das
unterlegene paar das dann gewinnende
gebunden haben die paar unterstützen
dass wir gemeinsam für die stärke der
spd eintreten wie groß die angst vor
einer noch tiefer
eine spaltung der partei ist
demonstriert ein video das die spd
führung heute noch ins netz gestellt hat
danke dass ihr mit uns gemeinsam diesen
neuen weg gewagt haben wir wollen eine
bessere gesellschaft und daran werden
wir jetzt sehr konsequent arbeiten und
wir tun das gemeinsam und geschlossen
war
die botschaft ist klar nur geschlossen
sind wir stark unklar allerdings wie es
das neue groko kritische du mit der
regierungsbeteiligung hält nach
verhandlungen am koalitionsvertrag wie
es vor allem saskia esken gefordert hat
lehnt die union ab es geht jetzt darum
nicht über parteien zu diskutieren
sondern die frage für welchen
herausforderungen steht deutschland
dieses land gut zu regieren und dafür
gibt es eine grundlage und das ist der
koalitionsvertrag der zwischen der spd
und der union geschlossen wurde
für die spd brechen neue zeiten an für
die große koalition könnten die tage
dagegen gezählt sein
und norbert walter borjans ist uns
zugeschaltet guten abend herr walter
borjans gute versorger die mulmig ist
ihnen angesichts der historischen
verantwortung die sie da jetzt für ihre
partei übernehmen werden
mulmig ist mir gar nicht im gegenteil
ich freue mich natürlich über das
ergebnis aber ich bin mir schon sehr
bewusst was das für eine riesige aufgabe
ist die da auf ihn zukommt
an dem amt sind schon eine menge sehr
erfahrener spd-politiker bescheid hat
darunter ein bundeskanzler ein ex
ministerpräsident ein urgestein zuletzt
wie andrea nahles oder ein schwergewicht
wie sigmar gabriel scheint so als wenn
man im willy-brandt-haus besser keine
fehler macht naja gut man sollte
nirgends fehler machen aber ich glaube
dass gerade mal das neue verfahren dass
wir die mitgliedschaft haben entscheiden
lassen und das ist eben gerade nicht
diejenigen sind die praktisch schon
immer in den im führungszirkel gesessen
haben dass das auch neue chance eröffnet
denn sie haben gerade eben einige
aufgezählt die das war ja offenbar nicht
die garantie dafür dass alles
funktioniert hat also finde ich den
versuch mal die basis wieder so schön
heißt damit der führung in berlin wieder
enger zu verzahnen ist eine sehr
aufregende aber eben auch nur für mich
jedenfalls sehr interessante
herausforderung ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass das wirklich
funktionieren kann von dieser basis hat
sich aber auch nur die hälfte dazu
aufraffen können überhaupt mitzumachen
bei dieser wahl
na ja wir wissen ja dass bei vielen
mitgliederbefragungen auch in anderen
parteien
wenn man die 50 prozent grenze ein stück
überschreitet dass das eigentlich ein
normaler wert ist ich gebe zu bei einer
solchen frage würde ich mir auch
wünschen dass 100 prozent der mitglieder
sagen ich will mit entscheiden wird
diese partei führt das ist einfach nicht
realistisch wir müssen davon ausgehen 54
prozent ist ein anständiger wert und er
sagt auch ein stück darüber aus was
vielleicht die anderen denken die nicht
gegangen sind denn die hätten ja nicht
alle nur einen oder eine gewählt und
verdanken sie diese wahl sie und fresken
auch der mobilisation kraft der jusos
die werden nun aber auch erwarten dass
sie liefern und liefern das heißt in
deren sicht raus aus der großen
koalition
also wir haben eigentlich oder ich kann
also auch jetzt für mich persönlich in
mann aus meiner vergangenheit noch mal
sagen den zuspruch vieler menschen im
übrigen auch der jusos aber eben auch
ganz andere gruppen von vielen
oberbürgermeistern aus den kommunen vom
managerkreis der
friedrich-ebert-stiftung in nordrhein
westfalen also sehr unterschiedlichen
leuten gerade daher bekommen dass sie
mich kennen gelernt haben als jemanden
der nicht irgendwo sitzt und auf anrufe
wartet was er tun soll und auch die
jusos wissen dass sie sich durchaus
jemand mit einem eigenen kopf an die
spitze mit gewählt haben neben vielen
anderen aber dass die jusos schwung
gebracht haben in die debatte und das
auch kevin kühnert dass keine angst noch
gar nicht beschreiben das ist jetzt aber
keine antwort auf die frage ob sie die
frau es kann das ja auch ausdrücklich
will aus der großen koalition so schnell
wie möglich aussteigen werde
wir haben heute schon an verschiedenen
stellen und ich immer wieder auch gesagt
die frage ja oder nein zur groko ist
nicht die zentrale frage es geht um
inhalte ich halte eine große koalition
nicht für der weisheit letzter schluss
die ist grund dafür dass die partei so
klein geworden ist dass ränder so stark
geworden sind also muss man aber in
dieser großen koalition drin und da wir
sind erstmal drin und das heißt die
frage ist kann ich menschen vermitteln
dass ich rausgehe das kann ich nicht in
der nämlich die frage beantworten nein
ich will nicht im großen koalition sein
sondern ich muss die themen ansprechen
und an den themen wird sich entscheiden
was mit diesem partner geht und was
nicht muss jetzt gehen wir davon aus
dass die union vielleicht keine lust hat
und sie weiter die debatte führte
parteitag aber der parteitag hatte hatte
ich jetzt durch die mitglieder hier auch
einen ein votum bekommen und das ist ja
nicht nur eine personalentscheidung
sondern auch eine richtungsentscheidung
jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus dass die
cdu/csu keine lust haben den
koalitionsvertrag in der aufzuschnüren
nach gerade mal zwei jahren mehr
reagieren sie dann gibt es dann ein
rückzug aus der großen koalition
es gibt für mich auch nicht unbedingt
uns aus münchen hören aber ich weiß zum
beispiel dass herr lehmann von einem
nötigen update spricht dass die
kanzlerin in den haushaltsberatungen
davon gesprochen hat dass wir uns jetzt
nochmal verschärft dem thema klimaschutz
dem thema auseinanderdriften der
gesellschaft zuwenden müssen der
transformation in der
automobilwirtschaft sind ja alles themen
die darauf deuten dass auch die cdu weiß
dass man etwas ändern muss
möglicherweise sogar in eine ähnliche
richtung wie wir
und deswegen glaube ich dass man ist das
alles nicht so heiß gegessen wird wie es
gekocht wird die frage ist nicht einfach
rein oder raus die frage ist was
erwarten die menschen von uns und sie
ist diese koalition in der lage da uns
voranzubringen oder ist sie das nicht
und daran entscheidet sich ob das die
richtige lösung fürs land ist oder nicht
mehr weiter bei uns für das gespräch
das gespräch habe mir vor 2 stunden
geführt nun berühren die entscheidungen
der spd ja nicht nur die spd und deren
mitglieder sondern die ganze regierung
und damit auch das ganze land theo koll
die wahl dieses neuen führungsduos die
wird insofern ja auch eine
denksportaufgabe für kanzleramt im
konrad adenauer haus nicht werden davon
kann man ausgehen die denkaufgabe wurde
offensichtlich schon erledigt ich habe
heute abend aus führenden unionskreisen
sofort eine nachricht bekommen
man sei auf zitat alles vorbereitet die
union wird jetzt wohl erstmal den
parteitag nächste woche abwarten ich
würde die vorhersage wagen das die union
da bereit sein wird weitere kompromisse
zu schultern um diese regierung zu
retten aber bei der von ascon und walter
borjans der erwähnten forderungsliste
also beispielsweise zwölf euro
mindestlohn milliarden-investitionen
aufgabe der schwarzen null deutlich
höhere co2 preise
ich glaube da dürfte bei der union rasch
irgendwann der
belastungs punkt überschritten sein also
was jemand hier schon scherzhaft den
crocs it genannt hat also den möglichen
ausstieg aus der groko ich glaube der
ist heute etwas näher gerückt
allerdings wären neuwahlen zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt doch für beide seiten auch
noch ziemlich riskant angenähten hat
absolut also aus einer laufenden
regierung auszusteigen und neuwahlen
auszulösen dürfte auch bei vielen spd
wählern nicht auf wohlgefallen stoßen
angela merkel ist ja auch unter
sozialdemokraten durchaus beliebt und
die spd liegt dem jüngsten
politbarometer für 13 prozent also für
eine rot-rot-grüne oder genauer gesagt
ja grün rot rote mehrheit würde ist gar
nicht reichen es droht also der spd dann
der ritt in die opposition
walter borjans wollte ja vor einiger
zeit schon überhaupt gar keinen
kanzlerkandidaten mehr aufstellen für
die union stellt sich das problem dass
sie derzeit schlicht keinen
überzeugenden kanzlerkandidaten hat und
dennoch muss man sagen
seit heute ist der koalition skip einer
notgemeinschaft deutlich brüchiger
geworden dann geschafft die einschätzung
ziehe nach berlin noch eine partei hat
sich heute neu aufgestellt allerdings im
gegensatz zur spd relativ frei von
überraschungen und drama auf dem
parteitag der afg lief alles nach plan
der parteiführung york deuten darf
weitermachen und alexander gauland bekam
den von ihm gewünschten ostdeutschen
nachfolger heikle themen die
parteispendenaffäre und beobachtung
durch den verfassungsschutz wurden heute
noch weitgehend ausgeklammert
das verfassungsschutz problem spielte
wenn nur indirekt eine rolle der die
delegierten entschieden sich für die
jeweils weniger radikal auftretenden
kandidaten oliver ich habe berichtet er
sich gedacht hatte dass der sogenannte
flügel umhören höke heute die machtfrage
in der afg stellt sah sich getäuscht
der flügel den der verfassungsschutz als
prüf fall behandelt hat sich heute
ausgesprochen zurückgehalten
am mittag gab sich heute ungewohnt
realpolitisch wir haben heute vor allem
der bundesvorstand unserer partei zu
wählen vorfeld des bundesparteitages
wurde nimmt der stimmen laut dass es
sich um eine richtungsentscheidung geht
das kann ich nicht erkennen wir sind
eine mittlerweile doch konsolidierte
partei wie sehr erfolgreich unterwegs
ist und wohin diese konsolidierte partei
unterwegs sein soll gab die
parteiführung klar und deutlich vor
die afg soll an ihrer
regierungsfähigkeit arbeiten opposition
reicht der afg nicht mehr und wenn grüne
rote und dunkelroten zusammengehen wird
der tag kommen an dem eine geschwächte
cdu nur noch eine option hat uns das ist
eine notlage und diese notlage zwingt
uns dazu verdammt schnell zu lernen und
ich sage es klipp und klar wir müssen
nun regierungswillig und fähig werden
das ist uns aufgetragen
das ist die aufgabe für die nächsten
zwei jahre mit dieser linie war der
parteivorstand heute erfolgreich leiten
würde als bundessprecher wiedergewählt
mit 69 prozent der stimmen setzte er
sich gegen zwei mitbewerber durch
und auch der wunschkandidat für den
zweiten sprecherposten kam durch tino
cooper bundestagsabgeordnete aus sachsen
in seiner bewerbungsrede bewies er dass
er auch die populistische übertreibung
beherrscht das größte wählerpotenzial
sehe ich in bürgerlich-konservativen
lager bei den menschen die keine
politische heimat mehr haben weil die
konservativen parteien
sie verraten haben bei den menschen die
es satt haben ihren gürtel immer enger
zu schnallen
weil sie schon fast nicht mehr atmen
können und bei den handwerkern mit
mittelständischen unternehmen die
ausgepresst werden wie eine zitrone
gruppe a kam in einer stichwahl gegen
den bundestagsabgeordneten gottfried
curio auf knapp 55 prozent vor der
volkswagen halle in braunschweig deren
schriftzug über den eingang von vw wegen
des parteitages verhüllt worden war
demonstrierten die gegner der fdp 10 bis
20 tausend menschen zogen durch die
stadt und protestierten
morgen tagt die afg weiter es geht auch
um unangenehme themen um die identität
bewegung um illegale parteispenden und
um die frage wann die partei endlich ein
konzept ihrer rentenpolitik vor legt zu
der tödlichen messerattacke gestern in
london gibt es heute weitere
erkenntnisse und damit beginnt die
nachrichten von reizvollen
der attentäter war ein bereits
verurteilter terrorist das hat die
britische polizei bekannt gegeben
polizisten durchsuchten ein haus in
stafford in mittelengland in dem der
täter nach seiner vorzeitigen
haftentlassung gewohnt haben soll
der mann hatte gestern mehrere menschen
niedergestochen
zwei starben an ihren verletzungen auch
im niederländischen den haag hatte es
gestern abend eine messerattacke gegeben
drei menschen wurden verletzt die
polizei gab heute die festnahme eines
verdächtigen bekannt es handle sich um
einen 35-jährigen mann ohne festen
wohnsitz mehr etwa zu den hintergründen
der tat ist noch nicht bekannt
tausende klimaschützer haben in
brandenburg und sachsen gegen den
braunkohleabbau protestiert aktivisten
blockierten zeitweise die abbaugebiete
jänschwalde welt zufügt und schleenhain
aufgerufen hatte die bewegung ende
gelände sie kritisiert die klimapolitik
der bundesregierung und fordert einen
sofortigen kohleausstieg die auslosung
für die fußball europameisterschaft im
nächsten jahr hat für die deutsche
mannschaft eine besonders schwierige
gruppe ergeben
das team von bundestrainer löw trifft
schon in der vorrunde auf weltmeister
frankreich und europameister portugal
der dritte gegner wird erst noch in den
playoffs ermittelt und jetzt die
lottozahlen dieses samstags sie lauten
die immer ohne gewähr
5 33 38 42 43 47 superzahl 5 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 5 56
jetzt noch die wetteraussichten morgen
in der mitte und im südosten zum teil
freundlich sonst überwiegen die wolken
an der see gibt es einzelne schauer im
südwesten kann es ab mittag schneien
oder regnen
dazu minus 1 bis plus sechs
am montag gibt es an den alpen und im
norden schauer ab dienstag bleibt es
trocken mit viel sonne im süden und mehr
wollten den daumen
an den temperaturen ändert sich wenig
das was man uns weiter geht es mit dem
aktuellen sportstudio und danach so
gegen 0.25 gibt es die nächste heute
express norden auf wiedersehen
[Musik]